[Music]
thank you
the further developed self which Rises
to become a being for self is Master
over the pure pathos of substance over
the objectivity of the light of Sunrise
and knows that Simplicity of Truth as
essential being which does not have the
form of contingent existence through an
alien speech knows it as the sure and
unwritten law of the Gods a law that is
Everlasting and no one knows once it
came
just as the universal truth which was
revealed by the Divine Light has here
withdrawn into the inner or Another
World of being and is thus freed from
the form of contingent existence so on
the other hand in the religion of art
because the shape of the god is taken on
Consciousness and hence individuality in
general the utterance peculiar to The
God Who is the spirit of an ethical
nation is the Oracle which knows its
particular Affairs and what is
advantageous concerning them
the universal truths however because
they are known as that which possesses
essential being are claimed by conscious
thought for itself and their speech is
no longer alien to it but is its own
just as that wise man of old searched in
his own thought for what was good and
beautiful but left it to his Diamond to
know the petty contingent content of
what he wanted to know whether it be
good for him to keep company with this
or that person or good for one of his
acquaintances to go on a journey and
similar unimportant things
in the same way the universal
Consciousness draws knowledge of the
contingent from birds or trees or the
yeasty Earth the vapor from which
deprives self-consciousness of its
self-possession
for the contingent is something that is
not self-possessed and is alien and
therefore the ethical Consciousness lets
itself settle such matters too as by a
throw of the dice in an unthinking an
alien manner
when the individual by using his
understanding makes up his mind and
after deliberation chooses what his
advantageous for him this
self-determination is based on the
specific nature of his particular
character this ladder is itself
contingent and therefore knowledge
supplied by the understanding as to what
is advantageous for the individual is
just such a knowledge as that of the
oracles or of the lot only that he who
questions the Oracle or lot thereby
expresses the ethical sentiment of
indifference to what is contingent while
the former on the other hand treats what
is intrinsically contingent as an
important concern of his thinking and
knowing
what is higher than both however is not
only to make deliberation the Oracle for
a contingent action but in addition to
know that this deliberate action as
itself something contingent on account
of its connection with the particular
aspect of the action and of its
advantageousness
paragraph 712 is a long one and coming
on the heels of paragraphs 710 and 7 11
before it in which we had this explicit
introduction of a new element namely
language Baraka right for the Revelation
the warship the engagement with the
Divine coming on the heels of that we
would expect it to be consolidating
those two and talking an awful lot about
language and language does figure into
it but not in quite as direct away
instead what we get is this initial
discussion of you know what we can call
the further developed self and we'll get
into that in just a moment and then we
have this kind of splitting and we have
a curious statement here following on
the heels of 7-Eleven where he you said
well the Oracle that's another mode of
language but it's that's for you know
the older religious views this is not
quite as developed now suddenly the
Oracle comes back in for a discussion
and gets framed as something essential
to the ethical Nation the zitika folk
that we've been on unpacking in this and
it's worth reminding ourselves that here
Hegel is not talking about the you know
belief of the individual religious
worshiper just by themselves or even
about
necessarily A we could call them great
Craftsmen of language he does mention
you know Socrates in in here and he does
also bring up Sophocles Antigone but
it's really more about
the individual within a matrix as a
linguistic being and the god also coming
into that now last paragraph We found
out that the speech of the Oracle is
actually in some respect alien to its
Community it's framed right it's it's
set apart
um and now we're finding that there's
there's more going on but the Oracle is
still being used kind of as a foil we
not only have the consideration of the
ethical nation and its Oracle but also
of Socrates and his Diamond which we'll
get into in just a bit and then an
acting and liberating person who is
motivated by their character by
advantage and in all of this we have
this splitting taking place or at least
distinction
between the contingent and this is kind
of a strange contingent we'll talk about
in a moment and then what we'd expect to
see instead of the contingent would be
the necessary but instead we get the
universal
so what's going on here well to begin
with contingent as we're going to talk
about a little bit more is dufeliga in
in German it's not
um Can another word that we often
translate as contingency or
arbitrariness vilkerkite
vilkerlikites right when something is
being determined you know arbitrary
we've actually lost the Latin and sense
of it
arbitriam is like choice and an Arbiter
is a Chooser and so there's a sense of
contingency resulting from the choices
of other people whereas the zoopheliga
ah things just happen to be that way we
could actually call it more random or
you know just the way things literally
The Way Things fall out right rather
than necessarily being
that way because somebody chose them
although there's often a lot of
connection Aristotle points this out in
the metaphysics that chance itself or in
touche what we think of as as Randomness
isn't really all that random there's
just causes going on that we don't fully
understand and that some of them may in
fact uh stem from the choices or the
faculty of choice the priorases of
people who were involved right but let's
put that aside for a moment and let's
let's start at the start
so he says the further developed self
okay so we want to pause right there
right further developed uh Vita
gabildita self right so building is not
just developing but also education it
can it can apply to all sorts of
cultivation this is at a later stage in
the development of the religion mediated
through through ART so the further
developed self that we're dealing with
here which gives he says which Rises to
become a being for self and notice that
being for yourself here is being
portrayed not just as oh it's a feature
of Consciousness you know we all take
positions on ourselves it's being
portrayed as a kind of achievement a
kind of development at this stage and
now he says a few interesting things
it is Master over the pure pathos of
substance over the objectivity of the
light of sunrise
so let's pause there Master is this in
German hair no it's Meister a term that
we've seen being used a lot in this
section
one who understands and can in a
craft-like way make something occur uh
it would be the you know sort of like
the architect tone in in Greek the
person who can dispose of these matters
so the master of the pure pathos the
pure when we say pothos very often we
think feeling but the pothos comes from
the Greek partheen to suffer the thing
that just is imposed upon us the pure
pathos of substance substances just wind
up being the way that they are kind of
in a way even though they have
essentiality as well over the
objectivity of the light of Sunrise
what's that a reference to well that
came up in the previous paragraph and
that's come up in other parts the light
of Sunrise it's great right but it
doesn't tell us an awful lot it's not as
developed so he says uh it knows that
Simplicity of Truth as essential being
which does not have the form of
contingent existence through an alien
speech okay so this is important knows
the Simplicity of Truth which is going
to be by itself and in itself right
and uh knows it as an essential being
which does not have the form of
contingent existence through an alien
speech how does it know it here's where
the Sophocles Antigone reference comes
up and we should remind ourselves okay
what if we've forgotten what was going
on in Sophocles and taking a besides all
the cool stuff about like it's the
conclusion of the whole Oedipus sequence
and you know there's all these family
Dynamics going on that that's all great
stuff and we've got the you know
miserable figure of crayon as well and
now we're getting to something
crayon represents the Law of the city
and man does that city of Thebes need
some law it needs a ruler who is there
in the midst of the city saying listen
things have been messed up I mean we
almost got conquered by one of our own
citizens who went off and brought a
whole bunch of archives here to try to
kill us all and you know take over the
city and we've got you know Oedipus who
came in and killed the previous King and
married his mom and sired these four
messed up kids who are both his kids and
his brothers and sisters and wow what a
confusing lot this is if there was any
City that needed the human law front and
center represented in crayon while it
was Thebes after Oedipus managed to make
a total mess of it and his his kids too
on the other hand Antigone
claims to be following not the
representative of but following
a law that's a higher law when she goes
to bury her brother who was a traitor
against his own City
so what is this higher law
this is the unwritten law the law that
resides within our hearts our minds this
is one of the origins of the idea in the
west of natural law right so here Hagel
calls it the sure and unwritten law of
the Gods a law that is Everlasting and
no one knows whence it came so that's a
quote from Sophocles Antigone
an unwritten law of the Gods a sure law
of the Gods a law that's Everlasting
three very important qualities right
it's never going to be changed it's
something we can be confident in it's
not written because it doesn't have to
be written we can feel our way or think
our way to it and no one knows whence it
came did the gods themselves you know at
some point in time make it up well we
don't have a record of that and maybe it
is binding even on them
so this is important this is what the
further developed self is getting to
know and this is something that we can
read into further developments as Hegel
is going to do very very suggestively in
this paragraph So let's go ahead and see
what he says just as the universal truth
which was revealed by the Divine Light
Divine Light in the sunlight right has
withdrawn into the inner or Nether world
of being and thus is freed from the form
of contingent existence so coming back
to this law right it's not going to
change it's not needing to be written
down because it's not something you know
contingent that can be changed later on
down the line like say written
constitutions can with amendments right
so
he goes and he says on the other hand in
the religion of Art
because the shape the Gestalt of the God
has taken on Consciousness going back
right we had the God as essentially like
the statue and it could represent the
God but it didn't the statue didn't have
Consciousness consciousness of the God
is able to arise through language
through shracha and language belongs to
a community it's not something that just
originates by itself it's something that
has a back and forth and is
intergenerational so the god takes on
Consciousness and hence individuality
now notice this individuality in general
isn't that a kind of a oxymoron there
well no no no it there's a certain sense
in which we use the word individual
right einzon or einzel night and that is
General isn't it because I have my
individual visuality you have your
individuality you know the guy walking
down the street eating a donut or
something like that whistling a tune to
himself different individuality that
could be you of course imagine you're
walking along you know hearing this and
uh you you're eating a donut whistling
to yourself like oh my God that's me
right
um anyway we can talk about
individuality in general in the gods
have that if we think about the Greek
gods for a moment right what is Demeter
right she represents something but she's
also a character in these different
literary works that we still have you
know last time I I brought up or yeah
two paragraphs ago commenting on that I
brought up uh one of the hymns this in
this case to Athena but there's hymns to
Demeter as well and so those are
literary Productions
so it is possible to be individuality in
general or have that so he goes on he
says the utterance peculiar to The God
Who is the spirit the Geist
of an ethical Nation right is it like a
folk is the oracle
now why the revaluation of the Oracle
last time he was like well you know the
Oracle not quite as developed a mode of
language it's alien to its people now
he's actually saying so the God can talk
through the Oracle what God is he
thinking about in particular well Apollo
of course right uh because he's going to
mention the billion uh uh interpreter in
just a bit here but he says um the
Oracle there's a certain
helpfulness
it knows the contingent right he says it
knows it's particular Affairs the
particular Affairs of the ethical Nation
and what is advantageous concerning them
what is nuts leak right or it knows
nutsley kite what is needful what is
helpful what is advantageous what's good
for you you know
um it's sort of like knowing somebody
and their dietary tastes
um or whatever allergies they have you
know if you know that somebody has a
peanut allergy don't give them peanut
butter cookies right and don't keep any
any peanut butter around and if you know
that they really like spaghetti and
meatballs
and not just store-bought meatballs but
you know homemade meatballs with you
know fresh garlic and parsley and all
that other kind of stuff and it's a
special occasion well you you make them
that that's nutslee kite that's that's
Advantage right there right if you know
that somebody doesn't like their Curry
too spicy you know where they like it
super spicy or whatever these are all
things that would fall under nissley
kite and this you know for the God could
apply to like the history of the ethical
Nation the relationships between the
various ruling class people and all of
their clients it could apply to the
geography it could apply to anything
that you want there are contingent
features that need to be taken into
account so he says the God knows what is
the advantageous concerning these but on
the other side
the universal truths now notice here the
plural
before we were talking about the further
developed self knows the Simplicity of
Truth
singular right
now we have Universal truths plural
and this is important because anytime
that we have a plurality of truths we're
going to have the dynamic that we've
seen so many times before where maybe we
have to Center on one of them and then
what about the others or we have to
think about can these be in
contradiction to each other but they are
Universal truths so he says the
universal truths because they are known
as that which possesses essential being
that which is not just contingent but
has essential being something that is
going to be lasting again we go back to
the the law right the unwritten law of
the Gods a law that is Everlasting and
no one knows where it came it's it's
sure we can rely upon it so he says
they're claimed by conscious thought now
conscious thought this and the denka
dankan
um conscious yeah okay that works
um
we might you know be thinking about like
Consciousness and self-consciousness
here it's more like thought that is
actually knowing things
um there's lots of different thoughts
that we're not knowing something
directly through right but this is this
is we might call it close to conceptual
thought
and he goes on and he says their speech
is no longer alien to it
but uh is its own right so their speech
is no longer alien to itself it's no
longer alien to the ethical people
uh it's no longer alien I suppose you
could say to the God but it there's a
sort of consolidation going on here A A
unification
and both of these sides are very
important now if we look at the next
example that he brings up Socrates we
get to see both of these sides at work
and I think this helps us better
understand what Hegel is trying to get
at here so he says just as that wise man
of old searched in his own thought
for what was good and beautiful
now
that's an interesting point did he
search in his own thought for what was
good and beautiful definitely
as a matter of fact we know that
Socrates would withdraw into himself
away from the contingent mundane world
of existence for example when he was on
military duty or in the Symposium when
he's walking on his way to the dinner
party that he's invited Aristo Bullis to
to crash he stops and he's like in in
his own head as we say thinking about
the good the Beautiful the true you know
these sort of transcendent
entities uh
beings these and Heights right uh we
would call them essentialities
so that's one side of Socrates but he
also does seek that out in other people
too doesn't he through dialectic through
engaging in dialogue with them sometimes
he manages to reach some sort of useful
conclusion sometimes not but a lot of
people learn on the way
on the other side Socrates has this
special thing that some people call his
sign some people call
um you know some sort of entity some
people have interpreted as he was
epileptic but that's probably a just a
silly
um itself very contingent explanation
and he calls it a diamond and what what
is a diamond in ancient Greek they're
not quite Gods they're not human beings
they're something that passes in between
right the dimones later on this gets
turned by Christian authors into demons
but in the ancient you know for the
ancient Greeks and really continuing on
through platonic philosophy they were
neither particularly
bad or good and as a matter of fact some
of them were quite quite good
um so in some respect they're a little
bit more like Angels than demons but
um they they would do things they were
intercessors in a certain way and
Socrates only acts in a negative way it
like gives him a little oh you know kind
of Zing uh that he can't quite
adequately explain it doesn't tell him
anything in words but it steers him away
from doing things so like you know when
he's about to uh make his
he doesn't really plead for his life
he's actually making an argument at his
trial uh he'll say my diamond did not
tell me to not come here so that's why
I'm here you know
um so it must be things must be okay so
the contingent what is what is useful
for us the diamond indicates that to
Socrates Hegel says he left it to his
Diamond to know the petty contingent
content of what he wanted to know that
zoofeliga in halt right so on the one
hand we've got like the the universal
and seeking the universal
on the other hand we have the what you
need to live in the world the
contingents and both of these are
important so he said you know examples
of this whether it would be good for him
to keep company with this or that person
good for one of his acquaintances to go
on a journey and similar unimportant
things and there's another important
aspect of the contingent that um Hale
talks about here not in terms of
Socrates but again more in terms of the
ethical nation and it's God
content or signs he says that in the
same way the universal consciousness
draws knowledge of the contingent from
what birds watching how birds fly or
cutting them open and looking at their
entrails or trees or the yeasty Earth
the vapor from which deprives
self-consciousness of its
self-possession what's he talking about
there the Oracle at pythia where this
you know Priestess would sit there and
sniff in the fumes of something and get
high and then say the stuff for the gods
right that is a contingent manner of
gaining Universal truths and so she says
so he says the contingent is something
that is not self-possessed and is alien
and therefore the ethical Consciousness
lets itself settle such matters too as
by a throw of the dice in an unthinking
and alien Manner and I don't know how he
talks about the acting individual the
acting person
when the individual by using his
understanding fershand makes up his mind
and after literally chooses valid right
and after deliberation
consideration weighing things chooses
what is Advantage advantageous for him
this self-determination is based on the
what specific nature of his particular
character he says it could be all sorts
of other things too circumstances
relationships but particular character
now this latter the character of a
person he says is itself contingent
zoopheliga did I choose to have the kind
of character that I have I mean you
could say well into the degree that
you've been building and modifying your
character over the years yes but you
start out with the basic building blocks
that you get I am always going to
struggle more with some things than some
other people will I will always be at
some Advan manages over other people
there are going to be some things that I
will be interested in that other people
won't be and vice versa you know and
that's part of our character which is
contingent and so
um he goes on and he says
knowledge supplied by the understanding
as to what is advantageous for the
individual
is just such a knowledge as that of the
oracles or the lot now that comes back
to something that is itself a contingent
piece of information but would probably
help out anybody who's confused about
you know roll of the dice or the lot
not all oracles necessarily spoke or
speak because there are people still
using them today in quite so direct ways
a priestess sniffing in fumes and then
uttering the language of the Gods
many of them proceed by Rolling dice
or casting nuts on a screen or by taking
Euro stocks and throwing them down and
checking that out or flipping coins or
and we go on and on and on about the
many different ways of divination which
then are interpreted and applied to the
contingent circumstances
so in a similar way the the acting
person does this as well he says
um
yeah just as a kind of knowledge of that
of the oracles a lot only that he who
questions the Oracle or lot thereby
expresses the ethical sentiment of
indifference to what is contingent when
you go to an oracle or lot you are
allowing it to talk about the contingent
but you also want these Universal truths
you're trying to get at something
important right so he says
the former on the other hand treats what
is intrinsically contingent as an
important concern of his thinking and
knowing
then he concludes with this really
interesting statement what is higher
than both is not only to make
deliberation uh the Oracle for a
contingent action right so deliberation
considering things on our part we treat
that part of ourself as if it is an
oracle
but in addition to know that this
deliberate action right this uh action
using Uber Lagoon uh is itself something
contingent on account of its connection
with a particular aspect of action and
its advantageousness so there's sort of
like a doing things at a higher level
but still in terms of contingency and
you know again we have the both sides
here we have contingency being involved
we also have the we might call it hyper
conscious or meta-conscious self
realizing what is actually going on
through the modes in which it is
comporting itself so a lot happening in
this paragraph as I mentioned not a lot
of discussion specifically about
language like in the last two paragraphs
but we're going to get more of that as
time goes on